- So good to see you again
in person, especially.
But, it is amazing your reach with people.
Like everybody loves you.
And you're so inspiring.
And you've inspired so many people
to do so many great projects.
But speaking of in person,
Broadway is back, so-
- Broadway is back, ya'll.
- I know.
(crowd cheering)
It's so exciting.
I know.
- Yeah.
- They have to be excited.
Everyone's been out of work.
So there's that.
But also just the creativity.
I feel like that is like
the lifeline of New York.
Like it's like the blood flow for me.
- Yeah I feel, yeah.
- At least as a Taurus.
- We're all like Tinkerbell and Peter Pan.
We need applause to live.
- Yeah.
Yeah (Kelly and audience laughs)
- And our cast members.
We're waiting for a year and a half
to be back up on that stage.
And, I gotta say,
not only is Hamilton back.
It's never been a better time
to see a Broadway show.
Because,
- Yeah.
- even the long running shows
have now had a rehearsal process.
They had to start from scratch.
And put their shows back up again.
So I was at the reopening of Phantom.
Yes, a couple weeks ago.
- Yeah.
- And it was just like,
unbelievable.
- Wait, I heard that Andrew
Lloyd Webber DJ'd after.
Did you see that?
- Yeah, sure.
Naturally.
- Because I think
that that's amazing.
- AL Dubs on the one and twos
(Kelly and audience laughs)
When we left the show.
- And a five, six.
- Yeah, look at him.
There he is.
(Kelly laughing)
DJ AL Dubs.
- So is it true that you-
I did this as well.
Did you perform at Bar in Bat Mitzvah's?
- I did.
- [Kelly] I did as well.
- I was, I didn't sing.
I was-
- Oh, I did.
- I was one of the people
whose job it was to just encourage
kids and grandmas,
and aunties to dance.
- Wait,
Were you a life coach at parties?
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I was like, no.
They'd say,
"Wear a black silk shirt and black pants."
And like, "We pick you up in a van."
It was 400 bucks a gig.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which was like my rent.
- Which is amazing.
- [Lin] Yeah.
- That's good money.
- And you'd go.
And you're-
And I was horrible at it.
Because my dog would be like,
"Hey Rachel, hey girls.
Like, wanna dance?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
You know?
And there were guys with me
who were really confident.
Like sort of good looking
like Long Island guys who were like,
"Yeah, it's really cool.
You dance.
Sometimes the moms give you their number.
It's like really great."
- Oh my gosh.
- And I was like,
"I am not made for this."
(audience laughing)
I am too nervous and introverted.
- Oh my gosh.
- But it was, yeah.
I left the last of my dignity
in a Bar Mitzvah in Long Island.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Twenty years ago.
- You know what though,
it all builds character.
That's what I'm saying.
- It does.
- All the jobs.
I feel like it does.
And humility.
But what do you remember
about the first time
like you were ever like on stage,
like in a musical?
- Oh, I-
- [Kelly] Like your favorite one.
- I had the most amazing
dosage of musical theater
at a young age.
Because I had an amazing
elementary school music teacher
Barbara Ames.
Shout out to Barbara Ames.
- Get it Barbara Ames (audience cheering)
- She's actually in Tick Tick Boom.
I put her in the movie.
- Oh, I love that.
- And she plays
Jonathan Larson's music teacher.
In the movie.
- I love that.
- I had to, I had to-
- I know but that's so great.
Like a little nugget so
everybody knows that.
Like while watching it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's so cool.
And so she would do something
called the sixth grade play.
She would music direct
and direct the sixth grade play.
And when I was in kindergarten
it was West Side Story.
And the whole school watched it.
And when I was in first grade,
it was Fiddler on the Roof.
And so by the time you're in fifth grade,
you're like,
"What's our sixth grade play gonna be?"
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And by the time
we got to sixth grade.
They ran out of age appropriate musicals
(audience laughs) for 12 year olds.
- Ah.
- So we did
a very unauthorized,
previous six years worth of musicals.
Like 20 minute versions.
So when I was 12 years old-
- Wait, you just picked the best songs.
- We just, yeah.
They did like, yeah.
They just picked the
best songs and were like,
"Here's a 20 minute Fiddler.
Here's a 20 minute West Side-
- It's like a variety show
of musicals I love it.
- It was four hours long.
- Oh
- Our poor parents.
- my God.
- [Lin] But.
All those parents hated
all of you (Kelly laughs)
- Hated us.
On our wooden chairs in our auditorium.
But I played a farmer in Oklahoma.
Captain Hook.
Bernardo in West Side Story.
- [Kelly] What?
- An Addaperle backup in The Wiz.
And who else?
A son in Fiddler.
It was like just the most
amazing experience of my life.
And when you're-
- [Kelly] What a boot camp.
- When you're 12
and you play Conrad Birdie.
And you sing,
and all the girls and boys
have to faint when you sing.
I was like, "I'm doing this."
- [Kelly] I'm amazing.
- I'm doing this.
- I'm amazing.
- For the rest of my life.
(everyone laughs)
That's it, I'm done.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- Well that's a lot to like ask-
That's a high bar to ask of sixth graders.
- [Lin] Yeah, I don't remember
- I like her, Barbara.
- any math from sixth grade.
I remember the sixth grade play.
- I only remember FOIL.
That's it for math.
So anyway, you are a substitute teacher.
I didn't know that as well.
For some reason
I missed that.
- Yeah my first job
out of college was teaching
seventh grade English
at my old high school.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, it was amazing.
- What was like your
favorite thing to teach?
- My favorite thing to
teach was Shakespeare.
We would teach A Midsummer Night's Dream.
- And they were into it?
- Yeah, because the thing is...
Shakespeare's really boring
when you have to read it.
But if you have to act it.
It's like the best.
- Oh, you were a cool teacher.
Yeah, yeah.
- I was kind of a cool teacher
and I would, I had, you know.
Everyone would pick their names out
who they were playing that day.
And girls play boys
and boys play girls.
- Oh, see that's fun.
You act it out.
- And in acting it out, you understand it.
- It's like English/Drama class.
I like it.
- Yeah.
It was really, it was really fun.
And I, you know they
offered me a full-time job
and I could-
And I loved it.
I truly loved teaching.
And so I could see
the Mr. Holland's Opus
version of my life of like-
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I'll be here 30 years
and I'll inspire a lot of kids.
And I'll never finish my play.
And so I ran.
And so I basically was like,
"I can't teach full time.
I'm writing the show In the Heights."
So I was a professional
substitute teacher (audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I was basically a sub
at my old high school.
Until In the Heights opened.
- But you bet on yourself.
You bet on yourself.
- [Lin] I did, I did.
- And your dream, that's cool.
- And weirdly my future brother-in-law
was one of my students.
- What?
Your life is weird.
Wait, what?
- Yeah, he was still a junior
when I was subbing.
And then when I started dating my wife.
He turns to his sister and goes,
"You're dating Mr. Miranda?
From school?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And now he's my brother.
- I love that.
(everyone laughs)
Oh my god.
What a small world.
- Yeah.